you look beautiful you like the ocean
we're matching space now you've been to
a red carpet or two before how different
this tonight feel I'm alone if you
notice my posture than with me so that's
weird they are coming later on but I
feel naked I got kind of want my crew
with me the full fam coming like the
whole family supporting your wonderful
director just told me sometimes you
would message with dad during filming he
said your directors told me you'd face
time with dad and that he would give you
tips including like he maybe wanted you
to punch a shark yeah he wanted the
directors note to be instead of swimming
away confront the shark head-on which I
don't think would play out well he had
to feel nervous like you got to be
careful with this one or her dad's
coming after you know yeah I was like
you - don't even don't even go there
like I've let him take this one but you
know how it does tonight feel for you
has to kind of feel like a big moment in
your career and what you want to do from
here I don't feel a little bit
speechless I don't really know how to
feel this is for the first time my thing
so that's really cool and hopefully this
isn't my first carpet was there a moment
when you realize oh my dad's a big deal
and was there also mum when you when you
realized I want to be a big deal no he's
my dad I will never admit that he's a
big deal are you kidding me and I don't
know if I want to be a big deal we'll
see real quick um we love your
friendship with the bjurman girls it's
like you guys are two sisters your
friends are you brand new friends huh my
friend she was so sweet she reached out
to my sister and on Instagram there were
similar ages and they're just the nicest
girls though why not were you a
housewives fan or a fan of their show
absolutely but I won't admit that do you
have a favorite housewives friend
Oh New York by far very quickly we heard
the swimming was grueling how was the
physicality for you in this movie how'd
you learn how to like just the
underwater like that I want to say I
think out of all the girls I excelled
the most I don't want to make anyone
feel bad but I really enjoyed the
physical aspect
dad housewife's pants you know he's more
of like America's Got Talent you have to
give the stars type out I'm totally
outing you so congrats on them thank you
so much one of many Oh
[Music]